in 1989 Matt Groening launched the
Simpsons ten years later he created
another animated comedy classic Futurama
the series centered around a late 20th
century pizza delivery boy named Philip
J fry who gets stuck in a cryogenic
freezing pod on December 31st 1999 and
wakes up in a strange futuristic world
of new New York in the year 3000
Futurama had a devoted audience that
sucked up the show for over a decade and
now odd news everyone
here are some amazing stories you might
not have known about Futurama a
different name Futurama was in
retrospect the perfect title for a show
about the amazing world of tomorrow
still creator Matt Groening has some
other names but he liked better on the
first season DVD director's commentary
graining says that his first ideas for
the show's name were Aloha Mars and the
Doomsville but both titles were met with
indifference the title they eventually
settled on was lifted from the 1939 to
1940 New York World's Fair where
visitors lined up for the General Motors
Pavillion and it's exhibit called
Futurama
fair goers were welcome to the world of
tomorrow I glimpse into the far-off
futuristic year of 1960 welcome the
world tomorrow well you always have to
say it that way haven't you ever heard
of a little thing called showmanship fry
and homer on matt groening 'he's first
show The Simpsons several of the main
characters were named after graining
immediate family for example homer and
Marge Simpson got their names from
drainings parents Futurama as lead
character Philip J fry was also named
after graining father Philip was his
middle name
this means that Homer Philip graining
who died in 1996 had the unique
distinction of lending his name to two
major cartoon characters the voice of
bender bender bending Rodriguez the
sociopathic alcohol-fueled bending
robots is probably Futurama 'he's most
beloved character bite my shiny metal
ass
it doesn't look so shiny to me shinier
than yours meat back voice actor John
DiMaggio discussed his inspiration for
benders voice on the Kevin Pollak chat
show it was part it was part like drunk
at the end of the bar it was part of
slim pickins yes with the hair in a wide
wide world is the story they're going on
what the wide wide world is porches are
going on here throw that in there in his
road that there was a guy my plan where
alcohol and we know needs to do in
college and it was Charlie the sausage
lover guy he loves sausages the advil
kinda chill yeah right so it's usually
have hot too hot tight soy sweet hot so
driving they have worse it all kind of
worked any would listen more have more
sausages ridiculous and so as we can
through all that together in a planner
and I tell you offender interestingly
DiMaggio also said he auditioned for the
role of Professor Farnsworth with the
same voice you're accusing everyone of
course he didn't get the part probably
for the best
Bernard Lloyd Berg voice actor Billy
West pulled from two major old-timey
inspirations to create dr. Zoidberg
actor and host George Jessel I certainly
want to thank bill for that warm
introduction I was listening to her for
a minute and I thought I was dead and
after Lou Jacobi why just after 745
elevators down from 6 both of those
inspirations definitely give a Jewish
and Yiddish flavor to the character
which West saved he thought with
appropriate given the traditionally
Jewish burg suffix of the name as
already meanwhile is a futuristic alien
sounding word that has personal
significance the Futurama producer and
writer David X Cohen who while in high
school created a computer game named
azide he submitted it to brooder burn
software which not only rejected it but
spelled Coen wrong in the rejection
letter which it seems like something
that could happen to dr. Zoidberg
casting Phil Hoffman the late great Phil
Hartman specialized in playing
characters both of noxious and oblivious
such as bill McNeal on Newsradio he also
voiced a sleazy lawyer Lionel Hutz and
washed-up actor Troy McClure on
migraines other show The Simpsons so it
makes perfect sense that Hartman have
been cast to provide the voice of
obnoxious Captain Kirk a spaceship
captain Zapp of run again on Futurama
but after Hoffman's tragic murder in
1998 Billy West stepped in
the role it once talks with Hartman over
their shared love of old-time radio
announcers that's had a big booming
voices as well as a huge sense of
self-importance so West performs up a
Brannigan in that style as a tribute to
Hartman or at least how we thought
Harman would have done the voice why is
it still blurry that's all the
resolution we have making it bigger
doesn't make it clearer it does on CSI
Miami
it's the Beastie Boys future armors
producers really wanted to line up one
of the most popular rap groups of the
20th century the Beastie Boys to play
themselves in the 31st century too bad
it never actually happened according to
the DVD commentary for the episode
Hellas other robots in which fry bender
and Leela go to the heads of the Beastie
Boys in concert wipes are producers Ken
Keeler and David X Cohen went to New
York to meet with the Beastie Boys but
never managed to connect eventually the
band members were recorded during their
vocals separately well Adam ad-rock
Horovitz and Michael Mike ddiamond
recorded their tracks
Adam MCA York had a scheduling conflict
so ad-rock just did his lines for him
even after all that the group wasn't
entirely happy with the material that
Futurama writers had prepared in the
finished episode The Beastie Boys
perform a portion of the 1994 hit
sabotage a cappella oh my it's a mirage
telling you all it's a Sarah yeah that
initially been asked to do their 1987
hit you gotta fight for your right to
party and the style first refused
nevertheless there were apparently no
hard feelings because the group gave a
bit of a shout out to Futurama on their
2009 single too many rappers one of the
song's lyrics say that they'll still be
in the rap game until the year 3000 and
beyond the sad truth of see more
Futurama was always meant to be a comedy
but some episodes would occasionally
touch on fire service and the loss of
being stuck in the future having left
his life and a loved ones behind the
2002 episode Jurassic Park is one of
those episodes while visiting a museum a
FRA discovers the fossilized remains of
his 20th century dog Seymour Professor
Farnsworth tell us why that he could
feasibly take some of Seymour's TNA and
create a clone during the cloning
process
while earns that Seymour lived to be
fifteen he figures that after he
disappeared in 1999
Seymour must have lived a long happy
life without him and then the saddest
flashback ever broadcast on television
appeared Seymour didn't move on he
waited for fry outside the pizzeria
where he used to work for more than a
decade the episode ends with Seymour
closing his eyes passing away and
everyone watching in tears amazingly
this episode could have been even sadder
as revealed in the episodes DVD
commentary the writers toyed around with
fry finding the remains of his mother
and that then considering but ultimately
dismissing cloning her that didn't stop
them from taking a tear-jerking dive in
to fries mommy issues in another episode
of course I can't stand to see him like
this I'll push him off the roof thanks
for watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you're not saying
[Music]